monsieur le président philippe bas pour
le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
et pour madame la ministre de la
décentralisation et de la fonction
publique madame la ministre
nos communes rurales sont désemparés je
ne parle pas ici du problème de leurs
ressources et du problème des charges
nouvelles qui se sont accumulées ces
dernières années mais je parle du
problème de leur regroupement
elles sont soumises actuellement un
mouvement pressent les préfets ont
produit leur projet de carte de
coopération intercommunale et à leur
grande surprise on voit arriver alors
que le seuil de 15 mille habitants avec
des dérogations pour les zones de
sous-densité a été arrêté par la loi
elle voit arriver des cartes qui prévoit
des regroupements de 75 mille cent mille
deux cent mille habitants bien au-delà
des limites naturelles des bassins de
vie
dans le même temps elles savent qu'elles
ont cet instrument nouveau qui est celui
de la commune nouvelle qui a été proposé
par les réflexions de l'assemblée des
maires de france de l'association des
maires de france madame il faut
desserrer les calendriers il faut
permettre de coordonner le calendrier de
création des nouvelles intercommunalités
avec celui des communes nouvelles
ils font que nous puissions créer des
communes nouvelles l'année prochaine
avec les mêmes avantages que cette année
et il faut que les nouveaux
regroupements intercommunaux se voit
donner un peu plus de temps à ce moment
là le processus pour se poursuivre dans
des conditions normales sinon il
entraînera de grandes difficultés
je vous demande instamment de prévoir le
desserrement de ces calendriers et leur
coordination
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame marylise lebranchu milices de
l'os décentralisée sur la fonction
publique pour deux minutes maximum
madame le ministre merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs messieurs les sénateurs
philippe bas effectivement deux choses
dans votre question sur les cartes
d'abord et très rapidement parce que je
n'ai que deux minutes
on a nous avons demandé aux préfets de
présenter des cartes le plus de façon la
plus ambitieuse possible pour qu'il ya
une discussion pour qu'il y ait une
discussion pour qu'il ya une discussion
ensuite les bornes ont été fixées par la
loi et donc quinze mille ou 5000
habitants donc les bornes sont fixées
par la loi après l'essai décisif rend
leur travail donc ses voeux n'est pas le
sujet comme une nouvelle les communes
nouvelles secret dans deux types de
conduite de conditions soient
effectivement de temps en temps pour
s'opposer à une intercommunalité mais
elles sont assez peu nombreux
soit parce que les communes sont petites
et que la demande de services est
importante et la loi qui avait été
présentée par monsieur pélissard alors
anciens maintenant ancien président des
maires de france il venait me christine
pires bonne le permet ensuite le délai
le délai concerne bien sûr la création
avec le maintien des dgf
je vous rappelle que le sujet est simple
si on prolonge ce délai il y aura donc
une dépense supplémentaire pendant
l'année prochaine sur la dotation de ces
communes nouvelles
s'il ya une dépense supplémentaire pour
ces communes nouvelles
c'est à l'intérieur d'une enveloppe
normée et c'est donc moins pour
l'ensemble des autres communes
mais moi j'entends parfaitement débat
parce que c'est le parlement qui va en
discuter au moment du projet de loi de
finances si effectivement l'ensemble
pense qu'il vaut mieux enlever un peu à
l'ensemble des communes pour créer des
communes nouvelles
moi aussi c'est voté par le parlement ce
sera votée par le parlement
c'est un vrai débat que nous devrons
avoir au cours du projet de loi de
finances jeu conclut monsieur le
président avec toutes les cartes y
compris la notion d' enveloppe normée
que parfois on oublie
monsieur le président du liban pour 20
secondes
madame la ministre je crains que vous
n'ayez pas compris la question
notre problème notre problème s'il y a
de grandes intercommunalités il faut
rétablir de la proximité avec les
communes nouvelles
laisser le temps aux maires des communes
rurales de créer des communes nouvelles
pour pouvoir faire évoluer
intelligemment les intercommunalités